[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
wednesday
of chess on psychology
um i am reading the chat seems like
people are
very ready i'm glad about that
um
yeah it's kind of interesting because we
have been doing this
sicilian
um
opening from white
for quite a while now and we're finally
at the
the
i want to call it the mother of dragon
you know well actually that would be
better for dragon never mind it's my
dwarf but the miner is very much more
like a beast than
dragon so
sorry my jokes failed
anyways help in the chat and in the
comments with what should we call the
this title because
i had the mother of dragons in mind but
that actually really doesn't work
because this has nothing to do with
dragons
ah the grand enchilada we can go with
that actually yeah let's go with the
grand enchilada why not i'm a little
hungry anyways
yeah it's um
we are working on a little
nighter today
i and probably next week actually
there's chance we'll do the week after
that two or the next time with me too
because just
neither of us is a monster oh there you
go title of next week schneider is a
monster
it's interesting because i was trying to
come up with just like one solid nine
and then i just couldn't i don't have
the hearts for it uh so let's just kind
of jump into it if we so far we've done
maroxy
last year quite a while back
then we did khan shivaningan we did some
side lanes here and there
so um feel free to check those and feel
um
good about them
now we're gonna be doing night off after
that we're gonna most likely do dragon
and rouser and
especially coffin oh my god i don't
think it's ever going to end
all right
let's go um most likely we'll also do a
poll to do something else like besides
the openings in the next few weeks
because if i'm doing openings every
every week i feel like i might lose my
objectivity
anywho
people are asking for draws just draw
lines i mean
i can't recommend one or two that's are
just gonna be so equal and dry that
you and your opponents will sit there
and just stare into each other eyes but
all right let's just run running through
it
um i'm gonna again this is not a by all
means
like a com comprehensive
opening recommendation because if i
could do that in just a week or if in
just like one or two hours i think i
would need a new title to be able to do
that i mean maybe like it
super
teacher master that's not a thing you
can't you can't be teaching that's
that fast these deep
of lines but
let's go ahead and do this also let me
kill the audio there you go
um i also want to be talking about
bishop b5
uh most likely i will be talking about
that
the later on so not today because that's
a whole different world by itself so d4
is the most commonly played
i also play this most common
take take knight f6 knight c3 a6 if
you're looking for e6 and stuff go back
to last week if you want g6 fast forward
to january
and if asics there are
so
many many oh my god many lines to do
here
that i don't even know if i'm if i
actually you know what let me do this so
i can just be fun uh bishop g5 first
things off bishop g5 if you want to whoa
i did not do that if you want to do
bishop g5 hey stop messing
if you want to do bishop g5
okay this is not working why isn't it
letting me play is there anybody else in
this study that might be no
you know what it's just you know not
letting me play bishop g5 wait what's
happening i don't know i keep trying to
do this and it goes back why
let me play vision g5
okay let's try a different move let's
let me play f4
uh
come on let me refresh the page
okay it maybe maybe it will let me do
this now
good
[Laughter]
um have you seen this before it doesn't
let me make my bishop g5 come on man
bishop g5 is the main move let me do
bishop g5 you know what i'm just going
to hold it here and talk about it for a
second because we're not actually going
to be talking about mission g5
um
bishop g5 is very interesting but we're
not going to be talking about that
because that's a whole different um
thing
we can be for bishop g5 though if you
want to do bishop g5
i do recommend negi's book
he he did a bunch of volumes few years
back on sicilian
and french and carl khan
i believe pierce
and philidor
basically white yeah
so for bishop g5 do go ahead and check
that out it's a great book great author
everything is super duper about it
maybe it will look up nevermind
okay so the computer does not let me
play bishop g5 so we're going to move on
there are so many many other moves too
bishop e3 is another common one
that i've also played
there are multiple different ways that
black can play against it
also for bishop e3 you have options you
can want to do short castle you can want
to do
wait do you want to do long castle short
castle you have
options
first things i want to do is talk about
your options first bishop c4 i've played
that so we're going to talk about that a
little bishop e2 i've done that we can
talk about that a little too i'm getting
f3 yeah f3 is also another possibility
very interesting i've also got queen d3
here
i kind of liked it to be honest i played
f4 and
f4 was very targeted like i knew what my
opponent was going to play and i had
prepared this beforehand so i went ahead
and played it also f4 i'll definitely be
showing it for today because
i can't resist it was against um this
sweet tiny kid robbie kev literally
when he like 2015 like he was yay high
it was really awesome and i beat him and
i still like it and he's my teammates
now so um we were talking maybe it was
like two two weeks ago in the gala we
were talking and he was like you know
sometimes i still remember it and it
still hurts and i was like thanks that
that that's very sweet
thank you so um sorry robbie if you ever
watch this but hey man i i have to i'm a
content creator i gotta use that
and it was still really awesome the fact
that um
my score against my dutch teammates is
so nice
um did i trash talking after the game
actually no because he was a tiny kid
but i do trash talking years after since
he came to my university
okay uh we're not gonna do king e2
that's the one thing we're not going to
do i've tried with h3s not really a big
fan
f4 yeah i've tried a4 possible g3
definitely possible nah rook g1 i know
that was a big thing i also thought this
knight e2 idea was such a big thing few
years back i didn't i never really liked
it that much so uh since it's my play my
playlist and my video series i'm gonna
do the moves that i like which is
surprisingly not bishop g5
all right
so
uh
i'm glad the chat is enjoying it you
know what actually
just because i'm in such a good mood
when i think about this f4 game let's
just talk about that oh no let me play
my f4 come on bad computer maybe a
computer
is protecting robbie come on computer
let me play f4
not fair man no no not that that f4 now
they let me play that at four no no not
that one
let me play the f4 that i played in the
game i'm actually manually trying to
find it ah there we go
thank you beautiful computer yeah so
i played this f4 let's start with that
let's start with something um
you know cheerful such as
me beating
teammates
and so for f4 it was very interesting
because i remember that i saw what he
played i remember i saw he had two
recent losses in it back in 2015 when i
was preparing this for him and it's
really made me want to play this because
i don't actually play a four frequency
oh god i went back i don't really play
f4 um
at all this was just one game
just preparation so that's why i also
have a chapter in my book called the
power of preparation you've got to take
your preparation seriously
you just have to
so um it's very interesting because f4
by itself was not a good move but for
this specific opponent who was a tiny
kid at the moment
it was very
very powerful because he had just lost
two games in it in the same month or two
so he had um he didn't have that good of
a
um
aspect on this uh
opening regardless of how much chest
knowledge he had
all right
um he actually recently became a gm so
congratulations by the way
uh e5 is very e5 is the one to go you
can't you can delay it with queen c7 to
stop bishop c4s but e5 is the way to go
you do have the option of putting your
knight on b3 or f3 i'm more fond of
knight f3 because if i'm opening up my
king sides to that much
exposure i don't want to deal with this
knight being on b3
knight out again queen c7 another chance
to stop bishop c4s knight d7 was played
and i went for a4 preparation i admit it
uh a4 stops b5 i want to go a5 and i'm
also
supporting my bishop c4 in this diagonal
if needed
um
seems shacky i don't know what that i
don't know the word jackie
but it does definitely seem tricky if i
try to short castle
uh so now finally bishop c4 queen c7 and
my first question to the audience what
do we do do we pull back or do we try to
defend
with a queen
also in person people i don't really see
you sorry you're super dark i'm super
light
also actually
almost both of you are hidden behind the
camera so
okay
okay the chat is voting for queenie two
so far
no i have a
bishop moving backwards too nice
okay fake morris is talking about bishop
b3
queen d4 up
not perhaps i mean i like my queen i
don't
feel the need to give it up just yet
um
good point if you actually
do go ahead and commit to something like
bishop b3
then you're gonna have to deal with the
consequences of what
i don't know why this computer is not
allowing me to make any new moves any
new move i try to make it just full you
know pulls back
any anybody has any solution for this
nah
scroll down just a little bit
no i'm not on the main page here
yeah
what does sync do
oh i
actually i don't know let's see
can i play bishop b3
nope
bad leeches
i guess glitches ain't getting any
treats
i don't know i'll do my best to research
it i'm not sure is it possible that my
line is too big because this is a
ginormous file but still
i've had ginormous files loaded on
leaches before it never
prevented me
all right well bishop b3 you kind of
have to keep in mind that knight c5s can
follow sooner or later so
is it worth it
maybe
but queenie 2 is better because you also
kind of get your queen in a file you're
defending over here you might want to do
rookie d1s at some point soon
and another fun thing if castle you can
start considering f5
i'm not saying you should but i'm
presenting it as an option
and
so
after queenie2 robbie took
i
took and then
now he went for knight e5
okay another question for the audience
what do you think we should do now the
bishop is under attack we do have the
option of exchanging that
question in the chat what would that f5
achieve well
if you do get to play f5 without having
to worry about opponents playing pawn to
d5 you get the chance to
potentially
uh start doing a king side attack
in close future with like g-force g5s
and your pawn on f5 is very strong
usually the problem with pawn to f5
getting the pawn to f5 is two things
they can either take on f4 or they can
play pawn to d5
yeah that's fair bishop b3 knights if
you were to play bishop b3 there will
there is no longer a knight c5 so that's
fair i think bishop
b3 is completely logical
um in the game i was feeling
too good about myself
and i went bishop d5 so with bishop d5
then
um my threat is if you dare to take
which the computer won't let me but
let's try anyways i will take back with
the knight
and i'm questioning the legitimacy of
your queen's position
and or take over here and or taking over
here there's too many threats so knight
takes d5 is not a good idea and
um funny there is a username
named rage against the machine
which i agree with you i'm i i always
used
i always use chess space but uh i to the
best of my limited streaming knowledge
chess-based does not have a streaming
option like if you're streaming on chess
players chess based won't tell us users
but they just does so
you got a little strand that's hitting
the mic
yeah that's it oh cool
yeah um so i'm a big fan of chess bass i
use chess bass for all my professional
um
chess conducts i guess
but um we care about the streaming
because you know
the platform kind of gotta yet let you
know that we're streaming so you can
come watch so
yeah
sorry we like leeches
all right so bishop d5 um
opponent
actually you know what i'm going to call
the kid by its name robbie let's go
robbie castle
and like i followed his lead and now
bishop g4
now how does this look
oh this is kind of a cool
username arab chess live
are you anybody i know i played a lot in
uae
years back
oh my god that was like five six years
ago
well doris the best i can find about the
moves is it maybe in the study you've
hit some kind of move maximum
because all of your classes are in one
study right um oh in the whole study
there is a move maximum there might be
welp
we can do trial and error after
afterwards yeah i'm not sure why it's
not allowing me to add even a single
move
but
yeah okay
all right
so
no why would you well white's position
is very desirable so is blacks this is
this is one of those type of positions
that both people have a very live
chance
it's very very funny because
um
robbie plays knight or robbie played
najdorf
pretty much exclusively but because he
had those few losses it's made me much
more confident and psychologically
messed with him not just because he was
a kid but because he had lost in this
specific f4 opening over and over again
i have to check to see if he's had any
recent losses
so
what do we want
yeah i'm sorry i guess the library is
not open today
oh maybe caleb will know
anyways so with bishop g4 what do you
think we should do
we don't want to make our king any
weaker than it is
uh exactly h3 will fail to up
never mind
it does not let me move
h3 um
will
result in taking sorry i keep forgetting
that it's
right now
anti-dorsi
ah
hello luis how's it going
yeah h3 i'm not a big fan however if you
want to prepare well for what if when
they take then move your king away you
have a lot of tension a lot of
possibilities in this diagonal and there
is a lot of
potential
of taking on f3 so
just prepare for when they do take or if
they do take even if they don't take
awesome i just move away from a check
line
yeah i feel like king king ish one is a
very um chill move another thing that
could be considered is bishop b3 because
bishop b3 you are defending your pawns a
little you know no more check and take
no more knight takes d5s but i'm
actually hopeful if they take that
bishop because i want to get that
outpost so i'm going to leave that as a
mini trap i'm also a very very big fan
of keeping tension and this special on
d5 is
um
it's like a torn in someone's eye i
don't know if that's actually an english
expression i use that's a very persian
expression hard to chesh
anyways
i like this i like keeping this tension
i like this kind of letting the opponent
have to make decisions king ishwan nice
let's keep it
um queen after roxiet i kind of i went
queen f2 that's all right but queen f2
gives the knight c4 possibility which i
regret a tiny bit
and so i'm not so
i don't know i feel like rick d1 might
be more um
annoying for opponent and i just kind of
go rook do you wanna just let it sit
all right
so i went
a queen f2 and i was lucky he did not go
knight c4 and he decided to take see he
kind of cracked under pressure a little
now what do we do about this tension
thank you yes
uh f4 is indeed a relatively old move
compared to in night or when people play
rook g1 or g4 or h3 or 92 or god knows
what those are those feel like they're
way more new and way more
enginey
so f4 is definitely more classic than
those
all right i'm getting some bishop b3
suggestions i'm getting some rook g3
suggestions
what else
[Music]
the chat seems to be torn between these
two
um suggestion of a5
my problem with a5 is that you would be
committing your rook to stay here
forever and ever
i don't know if i'm ready for that
commitment yet i'm way more ready to
commit to like rook g1 than to a5
yeah
and then after rook g1 let's say take
now
now what do we do
this is this is kind of the crucial
point in the game because
um
the kid wait actually the kid is weird
oh he was a kid 2015 how old was robbie
14
15. i remember he was tiny
but
ah i see some ideas about this okay
maybe this oh maybe this maybe this
he was 13 oh he was 13 yeah yeah 13 14
14 still kid
pawn takes to avoid um that's the thing
if we take then up like
if we take
let me give it another try
nevermind there is g6 which will stop us
to kind of like stop our attack
but now we have the chance to go for
this attack and after g6 i get to eat
stuff yay
and then i can just start exchanging
things off and now
this is another crucial point do we
accept the queen exchange
or not
so what do you think
do you think exchanging queens even
though we have extreme material
and kind of a weaker king
gives us a better chance of
victory or something like
queen d4 might be a better
shot
i can't remember i no wait never mind i
thought that's um for a second i was
thinking about ben feingold being a big
fan of um trades but i feel like ben
feingold's um catchphrase is more about
the f pawn don't touch your f pawns
anyways
yeah that's the thing you have extra
material so go for it exchange it off if
you don't exchange it off then if the
opponent could somehow relocate and get
more pressure in the second rank then
you're going to be begging for a queen
exchange so just go ahead and do it
already while this bishop is also in a
comfortable position and then try to
force rock exchange too because if the
rooks one pair of works get exchanged
then you can start eating over there
all right so robbie was a smart kid he
wanted to give himself the best chance
at
survival
but i was also um not gonna let him off
the hook too easily
i still want pawns
and i started to make it a little easier
for him to get away right
right now what do you think is the best
move there is a free pawn in front of
you but do you think there is anything
better than that
the move a the moves of directrix c1
rook c8 and a5 so far they have been
very good
but what's now
uh
activate the other rook
could be but think of opponent's final
move well what did they just do ah there
we go i'm getting few ideas in the chat
i think the first to say might have been
um
to su bukura
and brian yeah ricky eight would have
been very interesting
which doesn't love me
i keep forgetting maybe i get hopeful
that's wrong i shouldn't get hopeful
yeah rookie to pin it and then you can
just slowly slowly bring the other guy
yeah
i was kid and i was hungry i ate the
pawn
he went bishop d8 i think bishop f6 and
then bishop e5 would have made it harder
for me
but
i just went for a bunch of pawnee things
and i'm gonna kind of um speed through
the rest of the game because
we're not
like you know we're not necessarily
working on end games and this has not
much to do with neither anymore except i
guess this pawn over here
all right
um so for the rest of the game my goal
was to push push pawn make queens
and i did
i tried really hard
or i can eat pieces too
yeah
and
beautiful
i really enjoyed it thank you robbie for
this
beautiful memory
all right so um
we could try to
um yeah
yeah actually you know what
i like this i like this f4
i do recommend it but
this is by no means all of the ideas
that there was
f4 is interesting because for
f4 you would get the chance to um
properly
develop your pieces
i mean
with f4 you are kind of setting it like
okay i play the f4 i'm not gonna do long
castle i'm gonna get the bishop c4 if i
can i'm gonna cast shortcast though and
i'm gonna want to play f5 and e5
opponent plays e5 kind of stops it
and uh there is there's too many other
lines in it but it's not a
unreasonable move or unreasonable idea
so if you
saw this game and you like it and you
definitely
feel like you want to give it a try
please do
but do more research on it don't just
rely on one game that i showed you
oh i have some persian in the chat
asking if um
the k the king would it wouldn't f4 make
the king weak
um
yes and no but
the thing is like
if you're gonna short castle you're
gonna have a lot of fluff around your
king so i don't see any any
deep troubles in it with it
so
yeah
all right
um after
if okay let's go for some other line um
i'm gonna divide it in but for bishop e2
and bishop e3 i want to do those next
week because those are separate ideas
and they can transpose but they don't
necessarily have to but for now i want
to talk about whoa i do not want to talk
about bishop f4 because e5 and that'll
be it so that's the one who i do not
want to talk about but i do want to talk
about bishop c4 it's another very
classic option
what do we think about it
bishop of bishop c4 to be fair this was
again i did it solely based off of
preparation because i was playing
um
the first time i played it i believe i
was playing it against an opponent who
it was in a world championship world
youth championship and i really really
wanted to win and i saw she did this and
i was like yes i want to go for it and
so i this was 2013 when i tried it first
i really liked it my old coach rest in
peace um recommended that
and i really liked this and then i tried
it again after two years with gunai when
i'm a mazada and i won again it's such a
beautiful game that's i think to this
day that's one of my
favorite ones anyways we're going to go
over those ideas
and then i had another beautiful game
and
actually that was not a beautiful game i
had a very terrible loss in one of the
tournaments i got my
norms i think it was the first round and
i just played horrible we're gonna skip
that game
but bishop c4 what do you think why do
you think bishop c4 stops e5 why can't
they do e5 oh
it worked
i can't make moves
i don't have to
do errors again
lovely all right e5 what's wrong with
this
yeah exactly knight five makes it more
uncomfortable i agree
never mind i was too hopeful still
doesn't let me move
you know what someday we're going to
look back at this video and remember how
i couldn't make moves on leeches
and laugh about it
or drink to it
anyways
all right
so e595 knight five is indeed the
problem because if take take and it's
black already starts to get
worse um
and i agree e5 does weaken black's
position so e5 is not the move you would
want to play as black
e6 is the way to go 97 is also possible
but it's a lot of
e6 is another
beautiful idea
uh
let's go for e6 right away
what do you think we should do
i have at least four ideas in mind
yeah my tea is way too strong too bitter
okay um
moda knight f5 is not bad 95 is good for
whites it's but it would be not
comfortable for black right now white
yeah castle is one of it
um i would say an f4 on a more of a
maybe side
doable but
you know it could be
you would have to be careful because
this is a thing that can happen
and with e6 d5 could also happen
so we could simply just plan for that
i like i definitely love bishop b3 i
played it before bishop g5 another great
suggestion
a4 doesn't really do anything about the
d5 so i'm not really go for it um
one of the things that i remember i
learned very early on when i was
learning how to play against sicilian is
because black plays first move c5 for
the rest of the game
they really really really want to play
d5 or e5
so ideally we want to take that away
even when they play e5 they still want
d5 so d5 is a very very very
very big move that black wants to do in
sicilian and especially in naidorf so
it's very important to keep that in mind
and find ways to oppose it bishop c4 is
a one direct way of opposing it bishop
g5 that i initially suggested and i also
recommended a book for is another way of
opposing it so
i kind of like bishop c4
so far
and so yeah let's go for it bishop c4
e6
and i played bishop b3
talking about bishop g5
then bishop b3
possible
talking about bishop e3
another possibility if b5 you're still
going to come back
but
when you play bishop c4 the idea of
bishop b3 is very
very much out there like bishop c4 you
should want to play bishop b3 soon as
well
another thing is with castel
um
so let's talk about castle first because
that was my first experience with it
they played bish b5 then bishop away
then bishop e7 and now what
oh i see some persian again in chat i
see a hello and i see a how is f3
why f3
how does f3 do anything for it
somebody's asking whoa why bishop b7 why
not b4 followed by knight e4
you know
i like that i'm gonna address that right
after we come up with the move right now
i see a lot of f4s and possible a4s and
these type of ideas in the chat yes this
is great
let me go back and address
why not b4
the problem would be
the problem would be for you know what i
try to be smart
is that
i can't do it it doesn't let me
uh even if they take it you have a
rookie one you're gonna start attacking
over here when they move the knight then
you have bishop d5 attack that
it is not um
i feel like before you are yes if you'd
wear to play b4 you would get this pawn
but it's not worth it because you would
have to spend so many more moves keeping
that pawn while you're also opening the
king i don't think that's worth it
to put it simply
because
what's good is an extra pawn if you
can't use it or if you have to spend so
much time keeping it and defending it
so
all right there should be seven f4
castle and now what
thank you texas joe i'm glad i
sold you
i don't get the expression
you know um boar gesso i see your
question
i acknowledge it and i'm going to raise
it and i'm going to ask you how does my
cat move
let's go with that we all know how does
the night move let's go with how does my
cat move
i have a persian word for it but i don't
know how the translation would be in
english
all right so
i guess my main question for you is is
it time to play e5
fun my cat goes with great speed and
precision
you know you're not wrong
um the word in farsi i'm thinking is
lavend i don't know how to translate
that i guess the loose translation is
something with
um
very
um
i want to say ladylike that's not it
maybe grace not i think that's it either
yeah i don't have the translation for
lavend
if you are a varsity speaker and
you know it please type it in chat and
help me with some english
too all right
yeah i like e5
okay i'm seeing queen f3 in chat as well
people seem to like that too you know e5
might be too too soon i don't disagree
but
if take i get to take and then i was
considering queen h5
and i really really wanted to go for
this line
but um
also to be fair
eight years ago me
really wanted uh you know scratching and
biting and
fighting and everything now i feel like
i just want to sit there and just
know you until you resign
so uh different styles definitely
so i don't think i would have gone for
this
with my
amount of knowledge today but i don't
think e5 is a bad move it's definitely
too early though i agree a little
premature uh so let's say they play
knight e8
and rta is not a good choice for them
but let's say they do it anyways now
what do we do
they play the inaccuracy
so we have options now
hmm
queen f3 roar actually yeah let's go
queen after your
roar
i can't do it
um
and if d5 now what
look we're not going to be doing any
type of draw first right now
we're drawing
now what
uh queen h5 interesting but the same way
we talked about how opponents really
really after c5 in sicilian they want to
go d5 or e5 and stuff as white when we
do e5 uh when we do like e4 f4 we want
to go e5 and f5 and boom boom that way
so
yep
and
in the game opponent turns bishop c5 and
i had to take it deep breath because i
really want to just eat and bite and
scratch but i had to play bishop e3
and then they went bish queen b6 okay
here i could have the chance to go for
that
style of fighting and all those
fun stuff but i chilled and i played
night
back
not a bad move but definitely not the
best so what do you think is the best
this is kind of a like this is a dream
come true for white you have your pawn
on f5 you have the f file you have
center what should we do now
51 suggestion taking e6 is another
interesting suggestion so let's talk
about taking e6
so if we take on e6 what if they take
the
the horsey let's say we take their pawn
they take bishop takes d4
oh claudio
cool
yeah that's actually nice i'm glad that
you're studying psychology i i started
minoring and it's the more i
learn the more i'm like oh god that's so
that sounds so much like me anyways they
they always tell you whenever you're
studying behavior or psychology or
medicine or anything stop trying to
diagnose yourself and your loved ones
but i don't think
anyone can stop
so if anybody has a secret about how to
how to do that too please
leave a comment
i definitely like taking because if take
then boom
take take king moves and then finally
you promote checkmate
yeah
if take they definitely would have to
take and then you can play queen g4
defend over here attack over there
and
include more of your pieces
so i i think that would have been a
better idea taking on e6 first um i
went for knight e2
and then they played knight c6 and now i
took
a little too late though
they took back which now this was a
blunder tell me why
why is this a blunder
what's so different between taking over
here or taking with that
what do we do
what do we do what do we do what do we
do
what's okay they want this
we don't want that what do we do
yes exactly the problem is take take
take take boom check
they take back and we pick up
another material so let's do a head
count who has more
what's going on here
yeah people i mean was white we have
simply an extra pawn
but it's not just a pawn it's also the
fact that opponents pieces are just so
disorganized this is gonna be another
thing that we're gonna gobble soon so
they take all right knight f4 bishop
moves away all right now i'm gonna push
your king around and finally i'm going
to eat over here i'm going for more
possibilities and the fun thing is you
can't even take because that will be a
fork so peace activity is
worth way more than any material
so because if you have material but your
material is like if you hadn't if you
had a queen but your queen was hiding
hiding away here yeah in a long run that
might be useful that could be useful but
your queen over here wouldn't really do
anything right now
if you if you had a nice attack so it's
very important to figure out the balance
between when to eat and when to
prioritize the peace activity
okay so they played knight f6
and i went the other way this would have
been more um reasonably
um organized for an attack but i went
for knight c7 and i was hungry so i ate
ponds
and
this is still very very
winning
you can try to go for a more relaxed way
but this is just too good to be true
and all right
now this is how i ended up winning the
game
i'm gonna go
back back back to
move seven
where i played castle
i could have also played bishop
bishop b3
first and i did that two years after
this
original game so i started by playing
this castle and then i didn't really
play it for a little while and then um
two years after in war junior
championship 2015
i was playing as stronger opponents and
i really
wanted and kind of needed to win because
i was very close for metal
and so i
saw that in the same tournament
again she played this game
she had a
win in this as black exact same opening
i'm going to show you up until where up
until all the way through here
this was all preparation
and she had the exact same game
here i believe it started to change a
little
but
um
she
i
my coach and i were my previous coach
and i predicted that because she had
played this game within the last few
days she had won she hasn't prepared she
hasn't analyzed it to that depth which
is a very reasonable prediction when you
win a game you're not you're less likely
to go back and analyze it and learn from
it than when you don't win the game
so
i used that psychological idea when i
carter got it good
so my idea was
all right
logical logical
position and all i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to create some sort of a
attack
even though this is not necessarily a
super sharp opening it's a very annoying
one because black has to play it very
precise and soon you will see why
my opponent so uh gunai she played
bishop b7 actually kind of weird i just
had a conversation with about
i just had a conversation with another
teammate about her but i think like two
days ago i guess she's married now she's
younger than me so
good for her but
all i can handle is a cat
anyways
what do we think about this
why to move what do you think is a good
idea for white
again to be completely honest this was
all still preparation for another next
few moves too
john um
that's a good question
i
teach in an
english-speaking country with the
english-speaking chess club
so i gotta talk english and i have more
english viewers
so if you want persian commentary start
sending letters and
pigeons to the club
all right so i see continue plan roar
wow how do we roar
well yeah if pitch black tries to play
h6 yeah you're gonna take it
f3 well we we did all the stroke moves
to be able to go around also keep in
mind there are multiple ways of
conducting an attack you can use your
pawns to conduct the attack you can do a
mix of pawns and pieces or you can kind
of do mainly pieces or almost only
pieces so this seems to be going to the
direction of almost only pieces because
i spent so much time moving this rook
around
whereas i could have just pushed upon so
this is a different type of
attack all right
so i went for queen h4
spoiler alert all preparation
she went to rook c8 best move and i went
to rook g3 now it's very interesting
because it looks like i'm i'm
threatening something super duper big
but it's actually not really true
my attack is relatively empty
sorry but it is
all opponent has to do is going to move
the king away because if i take they
will take and they will take and it will
just be good for them because they will
get the chance to
punish me for eating material when i
also have a weak king myself
um bishop f6 does not work
um
what else
maybe king we want all right kingly one
is also a possibility but opponent is
not um hopeless they can't take they can
push they can't go for stuff so you have
to be very careful after king f8 again
sorry i had this all prepared prepared i
played real i played rook f3
and my idea was that all right i might
want to sacrifice what will you do now
to be fair white
white is kind of bluffing black has a
lot of different ways that they can stop
this attack
one of them being just king back to g8
if king goes to g8
i was
considering the option of repeating
because
my opponent was the higher rated the
higher title then she had a better claim
to the the championship and if she
wanted to
join the towel and repeat
i might have considered it i mean i
can't i was considering what if she does
that
so
lucky for me she didn't
and she did not play king g8 she went oh
okay another thing taking here also an
interesting choice if she did that
because it would question what i want to
do do i want to take with the knight do
i want to take with the pawn
so i think knight p3 was another
interesting
idea
all right
um
now after beef so she went for b4
some of the other interesting moves
could be queen to c7
it could be
rook to c7 and lastly queen to d8 these
are some of the other interesting ideas
um i was lucky she went for b4 now b4 we
are at a relatively crucial moments we
have a bunch of possibilities to take we
have a night under threats
there's a lot of stuff going on what do
you think is the most logical move to do
here
somebody suggesting knight e2 i don't
actually like knight t2
you have to play with a lot of tempo
i'm getting a knight a4 interesting
get rid of the defender of h7 by
bringing the rook that's not the idea
but this guy is under attack so we have
to choose do i want to save it or by
going probably up there or do i want to
take stuff over there are we ready
and the answer is we're actually not
ready for something like knight to e6 or
even bishop e6
the problem is that whatever you do if
you take with bishop they're not
obligated to take back they can take
here and this knight is a big defender
of this palm so actually you know what
let's go attack
and she made the mistake of playing
inaccurate and not taking this bishop
taking this bishop would have been her
last last hope for survival because
after take i would have taken of course
i was on the check and then she could
have played queen c7 to be defending
more on her king side while attacking my
queen side and if this happens
most likely black can still get away
with the king my queen is very alone my
queen alone can't be
giving checkmates anytime soon
let's say king g8
actually yeah and then yeah i can
consider doing something like that but
i'm i don't have enough
enough
material because they can take and then
block and then bye bye
so
take take take
this would have been interesting
but she went ahead and took knight a4
and when she did that i was like wait a
second so i'm not on the check she
didn't take the bishop that i need and i
can't just take it back later on but
this knight moved away whoa
does it mean i can eat this
that's a good question for the for the
video for the viewers can you take that
i'm getting a lot of yes eat
oh somebody's subscribing thank you
thank you greet
girl geek
nice
actually yeah we can
because the fun thing is
they kind of got to take back and then i
get to eat the other horse
wait the other piece on their sixth
string
and if they take back which she did i
get to take again with a check you take
i take to be honest i did not see any
type of checkmates just yet i just knew
that my position is better you don't
need to see checkmates to be a to want
to do sacrifice or play active all you
have to do is kind of just
trust your intuition and see that's
there's more possibilities
yeah exactly now i have a possibility of
another check now i all my pizzas are
active next trick d6 is coming
in the game she played drug c6 i don't
think it's there's much difference
between rook c6 or bishop c6 to be
honest
perhaps if she went for um
bishop c6
maybe a faster checkmate because i could
have gone for
this
i suppose
and i guess king face doesn't work
either because then i can take over here
or maybe give another check and then
activate direct anywho
she went for rook c6 and
now
should we take this should we take this
should we take this three options what
do we do go
her takes d6 more violence
yeah good good response
a lot of things to eat on the sixth rank
huh yeah rick takes d6 is indeed the
best one good job i don't suppose queen
e6 or bishop c6 are
bad but definitely makes the opponent
feel a little bit happier we want
pressure rook takes d6
she went for rook d8 and then check and
another check and what do we do now
very very close to winning just play it
accurately
whoops sorry
yeah just eat on c6 exactly if the funny
thing is if they take with bishop you
will still take back check and if they
would they would be kind of forced to
take because
let's say bishop takes i take you block
and i i still win the queen
that's kind of the
last
um
i don't have a good
grapple for it torn in their eye let's
go for the turn in the eye
yeah
so after six i think she took and then
she just resigned because the best she
could do was gonna take back and still
be under check
and lose a bunch of pawns so yeah this
is a very very great win i went i ended
up um getting the top six in that's your
world junior championship which was a
pretty great result they gave me a medal
and everything i liked it
i could have had better but um
well life
but
keeping in mind is
we talked about
two crucial lines in this opening
in niger we talked about
bishop
c4s and we talked about force two very
classical ideas i also introduced the
bishop g5 idea to you
because i think that's whoops that's a
whole different thing because i think
bishop g5 is also very
classic
and deserves more recognition so for
bishop g5 i think it's um
kind of like
if you are a bishop g5 player or if you
want some more classical approach bishop
g5 go for it just don't forget to get
that negi perry marjons perimer john
niggy's book he's um super grandmaster
brilliant everything i don't think he
plays much chess anymore but still
um bishop g5
and we talked about bishop c4
i showed you some bloody lines
and f4 which was also this one was
bloody okay well i guess today our night
off was very bloody next week we're
gonna be talking about some bishop e2
ideas some bishop e3 ideas and
the week after that or the time after
that because i don't know when the club
actually closes for holidays would be
bishop b5 so
not here actually
here this should be five
um feel free to
post any comments i will do my best to
come and take a look at them
and answer any questions possible now
we're going to do switch to twitch
so if you have any games you want me to
analyze meet us on twitch and i want to
say five minutes shouldn't take that
long to make that transition and submit
your games for lhs link
and for those of you that are gonna take
and be taking the night off
now pleasure
and i'll see you next week
[Music]
hi everybody i know most of you have
already seen
this beautiful book of my brother and i
that has been
published a little while back but i
finally wanted to share a small video
about it
i would really appreciate it if you look
into it buy it you can get it online
from forward chest so you can order it
on amazon pretty soon actually uh you
can get it directly from the publishers
from tinkerspublishing.com
[Music]
and i just want to tell you a little bit
about it so
beautiful cover extremely beautiful art
again
and i'll show you the first
page that is about
the chapters
and
it's very interesting because we really
really wanted to include uh topics that
a lot of people struggle with
topics that you might not be as
comfortable with topics that um you just
might not find enough information about
we wanted it to be a down-to-earth type
of book we wanted it to be accessible to
anybody who can read english and reach
us
and we wanted you guys to have fun with
it mainly because this is not the
opening book this is not a cookbook well
technically speaking of cookbook there
is a small part of recipe
at the end of it
beautiful food
very colorful persian cuisine if i can
show you that would be
amazing ah there you go
right
so
uh my point is
let me know how much you like it because
i want to do more books my brother wants
to do more books but we need your
support we need your opinions we need
your reviews to be able to keep doing it
thank you everybody
you